Selber Zeit mit meinen Kindern verbringen,
das war der Ansatzpunkt dafür.
Und zwar im normalen Alltag,
nicht irgendwann Freitagabend ankommen
und Sonntagmittag wieder los,
sondern ganz normal,
wenn die morgens in die Kita gehen
oder heute in die Schule gehen,
dass man am Alltag einfach teilhat.
Ich hätte gerne auch ein Jahr
Elternzeit gemacht,
also die Mutter ein Jahr,
ich ein Jahr,
vielleicht noch, bis meine Tochter
in die Schule kommt,
dann durchaus in Teilzeit.
Doch sein Chef war dagegen.
Den fürchtet er immer noch,
deshalb möchte er nicht erkannt werden.
Zwei Väter in Deutschland und
ihre Erfahrungen mit Kind und Karriere:
Jörg Asmussen ist deutschlandweit
bekannt – ein Spitzenökonom,
politisch vernetzt.
Der Sozialdemokrat war Staatssekretär
und galt als einer der wichtigsten Beamten
in der Finanzkrise.
Anschließend stieg er auf ins Direktorium
der Europäischen Zentralbank.
Und dann?
Ich wäre gerne bei der EZB geblieben,
es war einfach eine tolle Aufgabe,
Geldpolitik für ganz Europa zu machen.
Es hat bei der EZB
auch sehr viel Verständnis
und Hilfe gegeben.
Das war nur mit dem einen Hauptquartier
Frankfurt für die Eurozone
und dem damit verbundenen
faktischen Pendeln …
war das nicht zu wollen,
mit den damals noch sehr kleinen Kindern.
Sein Abgang: eine Entscheidung,
die für Aufsehen sorgte ...
Ich war überrascht, was für eine Welle
von Mails und Post es gab.
Und das war ein ganz breites Spektrum,
ja?!
Zwischen:
Du bist Vorbild und du bist Vollidiot.
Kleinkinder, betreut von ihren Vätern:
Aktive Vaterschaft, das wünschen sich
in Deutschland immer mehr Männer,
doch nicht selten stoßen sie auf Vorurteile
und Widerstand beim Arbeitgeber.
Er zum Beispiel wollte sich um
seine Tochter kümmern, als sie klein war.
Doch der Versicherungsvertreter hatte Pech:
den falschen Chef für solche Ideen.
Unser Chef hat es abgelehnt
und da auch ziemlich übel
drüber hergezogen:
Keine richtigen Männer,
um Kinder kümmern sich ja Frauen,
da können sie auch Strumpfhosen anziehen.
Alles sowas, also richtig abwertend.
Nach dem Motto:
Der Mann ist dann ein Weichei,
wenn er sich ums Kind kümmert.
Das waren so wirklich
gusseiserne Vorstellungen,
die irgendwo noch aus dem
letzten Jahrtausend stammen,
die eigentlich nicht mehr
in die heutige Zeit passen.
Hat mir aber trotzdem nichts geholfen.
Am Ende zählt das sichere Einkommen
für die Familie.
Den Job wechseln?
Die Möglichkeit hat nicht jeder.
Auch bei mir war es in dem Fall
nicht möglich.
Ne Abteilung wechseln?
Auch schwierig.
Es ist einem nichts damit gedient,
wenn man seine Elternzeit nimmt,
aber damit dann in zukünftigen Jahren
Repressalien hat.
Und die Karriere des Spitzenökonoms?
Von der EZB wechselte er nach Berlin
ins Bundesarbeitsministerium.
Doch der nächste Karriereschritt misslang –
zu einer der führenden
Förderbanken weltweit,
der KfW.
Streitpunkt:
Vereinbarkeit mit der Familie.
Dass das KfW-Ding nicht geklappt hat,
das ist ganz sicher ein Karriereknick,
danach musste man neu anfangen.
Ich kann sagen,
ich persönlich war da frustriert, ja.
Aber da muss man auch drüber
hinweggucken und neue Dinge machen.
Ich hab einen neuen guten Job gefunden
und 'nen guten Arbeitgeber,
der von vornherein wusste:
Ok, der meint das wirklich ernst, ...
Als ich dann sagte:
„Pass auf, Berlin ist wichtig für mich
wegen der Kinder“
sagten die gleich:
„Ja, das haben wir bei Ihnen
schon verstanden, ja.“
Ich glaube, dass es leichter ist,
ich sag mal,
seine Kinderbetreuungsaufgabe
auch wahrzunehmen,
wenn man in der Hierarchie
schon relativ weit oben ist.
Dann gilt das inzwischen
ein bisschen als schick.
Aber das ist eben nicht flächendeckend.
Die Frage ist:
Kriegen wir das für alle vernünftig so hin?
Er war nicht oben in der Hierarchie,
kam im entscheidenden Moment
nicht an seinem Chef vorbei.
Also, ich bedauere es für mich
auf jeden Fall.
Das ist eine Zeit,
die nicht zurückzubringen ist,
ich kann es auch nicht mehr nachholen.
Es fehlt einfach ein Stück was im Leben.
Und ich gönn das wirklich
jedem Vater heute,
der das erleben kann
und die Zeit aufwendet,
sich für seine Kinder zu engagieren.
Er war, wie die meisten Väter,
nur am Wochenende präsent.
Viele junge Väter heute aber
nehmen sich die Zeit –
am ehesten die,
die sich das beruflich erlauben können
wie diese Ärzte, Wissenschaftler
und IT-Experten.
Bei gefragten Berufen gelingt
nach der Erziehungspause
der Wiedereinstieg besser.
Ich wünsche mir einfach,
dass das normal wird,
das gilt für Männer wie für Frauen.
Dass es nicht als was Besonderes
angesehen wird, das will so,
das ist Teil dessen, wie wir leben,
wie wir arbeiten
und dass das wenn meine Töchter groß sind,
dass das völlig normal ist,
dass man eben arbeitet
und seine Kinder genauso auch großzieht.
In Deutschland nehmen sich Väter derzeit
im Durchschnitt 3 Monate Elternzeit,
Mütter 13 Monate.